in hinterzarten in baden württemberg
baut die gemeinde in ihrem skistadion
die altehrwürdige sprungschanze um
doch mit dem bauwerk gibt es ein
heftiges problems denn erst bei der
montage der stahlelemente für die neuen
anlauf stellt man fest sie passen nicht
an den alten tor deshalb hat die schöne
neue schanze eine lücke seit wochen
rührt sich auf der baustelle nichts mehr
dass so was heutzutage so passiere kann
ich hab gedacht ich höre richtig ja ich
war total geschockt ich konnte gar nicht
glauben ich war fassungslos da es zum
baustopp kommt ja einfach wahnsinn
skispringen in hinterzarten ist fester
bestandteil im weltcup kalender
damit das so bleibt modernisiert die
gemeinde ihre chance ein neuer anlauf
wird vor den turm gebaut kosten stolze 3
millionen euro bis in den oktober laufen
die arbeiten reibungslos doch bei der
montage des anlaufs gibt es eine böse
überraschung das stahlgerüst passt nicht
an dem tour es gibt maß abweichungen von
etwa 60 cm
die bauarbeiten werden direkt gestoppt
ein geplantes weltcup springen abgesagt
bei den ehrenamtlichen helferinnen und
helfern des skiclubs ist der frust groß
er den skiclub in das antut ist
natürlich richtig wir haben keine
trainingsmöglichkeiten hier auf der
schanze und es fallen zahlreiche
veranstaltungen im winter sowie im
sommer natürlich aus ja das ist
natürlich für uns ein riesen schock hat
uns einige schlaflose nächte bereitet im
rathaus von hinterzarten macht man
keinerlei anstalten das baudebakel
kleinzureden
wir sind momentan auf der suche zusammen
mit den architekten aber auch den
verbessern und den baufirmen wo jetzt
dieser fehler passiert ist ob es ein
messfehler ist oder ein
übertragungsfehler können wir momentan
nicht sagen wir hoffen dass wir bis
weihnachten jetzt dann den oder die
verantwortlichen festgestellt haben dass
den fehler nach jahrelanger planung
niemand rechtzeitig entdeckt hat können
viele menschen im hochschwarzwald nicht
glauben
es ist ja ein projekt sollte eigentlich
professionell besser geplant werden
ich finde dass der verantwortliche oder
die verantwortlichen für den
planungsfehler die zeche für die
mehrkosten jetzt dadurch entstehen
bezahlen müssen derzeit kann niemand
verlässlich sagen wann skispringer hier
wieder über den schanzentisch gehen
können und wer am ende auf den kosten
für die reparatur sitzen bleibt muss
auch noch geklärt werden